kenny le petit café et bâtissez gosselin
sont à cergy pontoise dans le val d'oise
où un rassemblement est organisé en
hommage à samuel pâtit sur le parvis de
la préfecture
bonjour à coeur il alors à ce que les
professeurs les parents d'élèves ont
répondu présent à ce rassemblement
oui vous le voyez derrière moi il ya
environ un millier de personnes sur ce
parvis de la préfecture du val d'oise à
cergy pontoise
un rassemblement qui suit les autres
rassemblements qui ont eu lieu tout au
long du week-end pour rendre hommage à
la famille de samuel pâtit cet
enseignant décapité en pleine rue il y a
deux jours et puis ici on voit que et
bien tous les bords politiques sont
présents il ya des élus il y à des
associations des professeurs des
syndicalistes
je vous propose d'écouter notamment le
maire de cergy ainsi que les autres
personnes présentes sur place qui ont
répondu à nos questions
je suis très heureux de voir qu à cergy
et ya un grand rassemblement d'à peu
près un millier de personnes quand je
regarde à peu près là les gens qui sont
là c'est ce qui pour moi est important
c'est que tous ceux qui pensent que en
france on a la liberté d'expression la
liberté de la presse
la laïcité bien comprendre ce qu'est la
laïcité croire ne pas croire ne plus
croire tous ceux qui se retrouvent dans
cet esprit humaniste et républicain ils
ont leur place ceux qui ne partagent pas
les lois de la république ce qui met la
religion au dessus des lois de la
république n'ont pas être là je suis là
aujourd'hui comme beaucoup de monde on
remarque qui a beaucoup de monde
aujourd'hui par rapport à ce crime qui a
eu de cet enseignant c'est juste
intolérable qu'on laisse encore en 2020
ces idées de 2,2 de tuer pour ne pas
dire des choses qui fâchent on a besoin
je crois de 7,2 cette chaleur collective
pour faire face à ce drame qui touche
l'éducation nationale et d'une manière
générale quoi toute la société qui est
interpellé par cette pas ce drame un
rassemblement qui se tient dans le plus
grand calme et le recueillement et dont
le slogan est liberté égalité fraternité
mais aussi laïcité devrait prendre fin
d'ici 14h environ
merci car ils cotisent comme je rappelle
que à l'image assez baptiste beausoleil
merci à vous deux